Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five one area code.
Who's calling today from nine five one.
Hey David, this is Dylan in California.
Hey Dylan.
What's going on?
Um, I was wondering, I know you specifically,
um, talk about how your identify as a Social
Democrat, not a democratic socialist.
Right.
Um, I was wondering if you would support theoretically
if Democrats like created legislation where
it gave American workers a right to purchase
the corporation that they own, that they work
for from the owners.
Would you support legislation for that or
would you consider that like two socialist
for your own political ideology?
Let me see if I, so you're saying imagine
that there is a, a company, I dunno, let's
imagine it's what, what kind of accompany
you could let, let's an accounting firm for
example, and one accountant starts in accounting
firm and after a few years they hire a second
accountant and then after a few years they
hire 10 more accountants and 20, uh, accounting
assistance and some administrative staff and
they get to 35 employees or something like
that.
The idea would be that a law would be passed
where if those 34 employees, in other words,
there's 35 employees, including the owner,
if the other 34 employees wants to buy the
company, um, that the founder of the company
would be forced to sell the company to them.
Is that what you're suggesting?
Um, yeah, something along those lines.
I would be against that.
Yeah.
Um, what would be your reasoning?
I don't know what a basis there would be for
the government coming in and saying business
owners are going to be forced by statute to
sell businesses they may not want to sell.
I don't that, that doesn't make any sense
to me.
That's not something I would push for.
Okay.
Well, fair enough.
Thanks.
All right, very good.
Thank you.
I mean, in the same way that, you know, oh,
I wouldn't allow the government to say you
have to sell other property of, of your own.
I wouldn't say that the government should
come in and say people have to be forced to
sell, uh, uh, uh, a business.
So just, that's not my politics.
Okay.
I guess to, to me that sounds like a lot like
us saying that's different than us regulating
corporations and other ways like it out.
I guess for me is that different than us saying
you can't like, right.
So wrapped in your hamburgers or something
like that.
Like let us like,
sorry.
You can't do what with your hand like,
right.
Like we tell fast food places that you can't,
You can't sell a rat in your, and your hamburger,
otherwise the government is going to come
and shut you down.
Oh, right.
Yeah.
Go regulate government regulation of businesses
is based on completely different, um, government
authority.
Then the government mandating that employers
that owners sell their business to employees
would be based on, so I don't think that it's
a good analogy at all.
Um, okay.
I guess I see it as like a moral argument,
like, uh, cleanliness is a value of ours.
So like if we value like, um, like work or
representation in the workplace, then you
would give them avenues to better represent
themselves, right?
Sure.
And that there are a number of ways that that
could be done that stop short of mandating
that people sell businesses that they don't,
they don't want to sell.
You know what I mean?
Dylan?
Yeah, totally.
What would, what would be a policy that you
would support that, like adhere that value?
I'd have to think about it, but it would have
to vary depending on company size because
what's reasonable and practical at small businesses
would differ from medium and from large.
But let me think about that a little bit.
Okay.
Well appreciate your show and thanks for taking
my call.
Okay, great.
Dylan, thank you.
Appreciate the phone call very much.